have you been getting
lots of people hitting you up about um
about scams and yes you told me
over dinner the other night yes i had
told me a couple funny stories they try
to get you to teach them how to do it
i was pretty [ __ ] stunned i'm not
gonna lie you know it's funny because
like i when it first happened like
i didn't say anything i just didn't
think it was a big big deal it wasn't
till recently i started mentioning it to
people like after boziac the thing with
john bozeak
had told me yeah about the guy i wish
i'll tell i'll tell in a minute
when he told me that i was like oh yeah
that's happened to me [ __ ] a bunch of
times
and he was like really i was like yeah
this and so then i ended up telling you
and
i've told other people and that people
are like that are you serious
i'm like yeah you know i to me it's like
why yeah that's just normal i'm like to
me all this is so bizarre
nothing stands out anymore you're like a
legitimate internet celebrity now is it
slightly flattering
that they're looking for to you for the
advice what
a little bit how many people email you
it's gotta feel a little good it's
kind of a little sickness how many
people reach out to you on a daily basis
probably from this podcast probably
and there was a time it was no you know
it's it's pretty that this part's pretty
consistent it's probably
probably maybe three to ten or fifteen
10 people a day wow three to ten could
be five could be
that are trying to get you to no no no
not that no no no
no what what no i want to say shane but
i'm gonna say hat rack
um what hat rack is trying to say is uh
is that basically supreme hat rack so
like like a year ago when i did that the
video
that the first video um was it episode
the first podcast
yeah the first part would i say what did
i just say video sorry uh podcast the
first podcast
the first pod the first episode that you
ever did on concrete yes
episode 40. yeah right the one about
your personal story where you talk about
your mortgage fraud
uh adventures right where it all started
right so that one did like
super good and then within weeks of that
i started getting these emails right
you know constantly getting emails and
after probably a month or so maybe a
month or two
now maybe a month or so whatever it
doesn't matter the point is eventually
guys started reaching out to me saying
you know bro if i could just
talk to you you know i just like to talk
to you and
maybe i'll buy you dinner you know and i
was like
just i don't understand by that point
people were starting like i think i
released
my book and guys were saying hey can you
can i meet you and sign and have you
sign the book
and i was like um i thought that was a
little bit weird like the first
three or four guys that did that i
thought and or wanted to just
meet me and buy me lunch i thought
that's really strange and i remember
going to um
going to my friend stacy and saying look
that this is weird
you know what i mean this is weird like
why would this guy these two guys called
me
up they want to meet me they they're in
tampa they're going to drive over here
we're going to meet they want to buy me
a lunch and just talk to me that's
weird right and she's like i don't know
you know
people like you you're likable i'm like
no i'm not i'm kind of a [ __ ] people
really don't like me she's like no
you're you have a nice you
people do like you so we went back and
forth and then
literally a couple days later another
guy came in and then like a week later
another one i was like this is insane
these guys all want to meet me they want
to mail me a book they want to do this
and
and she goes listen she said think of it
like this she's i know you think it's
strange
she's thinking like this she said
remember that that guy you sent me all
those videos and said i should
watch some of these and i was like and i
go yeah garyvee she goes right garyvee
i said right she goes if you could call
up garyvee and take him to lunch she
goes or you were
could go to lunch with him she was would
you and i went
of course my name is gary vee's like
awesome i i love gary vee
and she was like she's like why he's
weird bro
i knew you were going to say that
anybody who you'd say that about
everybody
but here's the great thing about gary v
is that
and she's like why do you feel like that
i said because it's like and this is i
already told her that i said it's like
the stuff that he's saying
is things that i internally think in my
head all the time but i've never said
never told anybody like the way i feel
he's verbalized things that i
felt and so i feel there's like a
connection there not in a creepy way
just like it's like wow bro i can't
believe you said that because that's how
i feel
so and she goes that's how these guys
feel and so then i stopped thinking it
was weird and i just started thinking
you know what
she goes and you'd be she was in a year
ago when you were laying in your bunk
bed
she was you'd have been thrilled to have
someone buy you lunch
and i was like she's absolutely right it
was like it was
it's like you know you don't drop drop
the weird oh this is weird no
you you should be thankful you should be
it's
you should be gracious and you know it
it's it's it's
it's a good thing you're i should be
thrilled by it i i should be you know
it's it's
it's great so i um so i started going i
went and the first two couple guys i met
they they
happen to both be in real estate and we
just sat there and talked about real
estate
it was great next guy signed a book took
a picture with him
talked to him he texted me every once in
a while that happened over and over
again
and then i started getting the guys that
were
can i just talk to you on the phone can
i meet you and i was like
sure what's up like i wanted to drive in
from orlando
and i was like yeah uh what's up so he
texts me and he's like yeah bro can i
call you and i was like yeah
called up and i was like yeah what's up
and
i said and he's like yeah bro man you
you know you're a legend you're this
you're that i was just like
that was a little over the top i was
like okay i'm not a legend
i'm a douchebag that just got a federal
prison i could barely pay my bills but
that's fine and i was like okay okay
yeah all right bro that's uh you said
that enough you know he's like said it
over and over again
and he's like bro if you know like if
you could just put me on the game
i was like oh that went south real fast
yeah
uh what game is that and he's like you
know the
whole real estate gang like you know and
i was like oh okay i was like yeah you
know
i don't really not really supposed to be
i really can't do real estate i could
kind of talk to you about it but
he's like no you know because that fraud
[ __ ] you done like that's some bad [ __ ]
like
right now i just do i do some credit
cards and stuff you know i'm saying like
little stuff little credit card here
little credit card
here you know i get credit cards and i
do this and i do that and
my buddies and i was like and then he's
like but you know you're on that next
level [ __ ] i know you can bring my game
i was like whoa whoa
whoa yeah bro you got the wrong guy now
i'm like okay
oh no no no no no no he's like talking
about how he's making a couple grand
here a couple around there but i can get
him in that million dollar i was like
yeah
i'm sorry uh i i i
appreciate you calling yeah i'm back
pedaling he's like
no i'm going to come down i'll break you
off too i'm like uh absolutely not now
we're definitely not meeting
yeah and i was like no no i'm good i'm
good i'm good
absolutely not no no no and i hung out
the phone
and you know because these guys don't
understand like this guy might have done
some state time for
i think he had said he did state time
for drugs or something like that it was
like you know
so first of all i can't i'm not even
supposed to talk to you and i'm saying i
like learning that during the
conversation
so we start back i start back pedaling i
finally got off the phone with him
and i thought wow that's weird but i
didn't think anything of it
next thing i know maybe a week later
i get another guy he same thing on the
phone
can i just talk to you for a little bit
i just want to talk to you you know i'll
pay you for your time you have to pay me
for my time just
what is it what's up he's doing
the the tax scam you know that they call
it the drop
no it's uh it's where you get someone's
tax where you get their social security
you get their
their personal information and you file
taxes
for them before they can file so then
they go to file on their job at walmart
you've already filed you've already got
the card
you've already got the the dump has been
or the the
direct deposited onto a card and you've
already removed five or six thousand
dollars of their tax return
and then when they go to file they go
you've already filed taxes
and that's it and then of course you say
hey this is fraud blah blah blah and
eventually you get your money back but
it's a hell of a
it's a it's these people have to go
through hell to try and get their stuff
back
and so yeah that's a that's a huge fraud
huge there's tons of guys in prison for
that the problem is it's drying up
so it's almost impossible almost
impossible but it's much much more
difficult
so you're getting rid of so the average
douche bag that was doing it can't
really do it now it's gotten way more
sophisticated there's way more
um uh security procedures involved in
the irs is catching them left and right
where before you'd file
10 of them nine of them went through now
you're filing 20 of them and one of
them's going through you know
so this guy's like yeah man i was doing
the drop
you know what that is that's that's like
i know what the drop is you know it's
like
why are you calling me why are you
telling me this like you know you know
because
i like i can get the ids i'm like listen
i can already tell there's no good place
at this point that this
conversation is going yeah so i'm gonna
get off the phone
no no no no no i love it when they think
they can talk me into it yeah no no no
you don't understand i wouldn't say
nothing like i wouldn't say you were
involved
stop bro stop stop it's like i hang out
the phone
so i'm not going to say all the things
that i said to these guys because it's
really the same thing i said to the best
one which
i'll tell you about yeah so i keep
getting these guys i actually had one
guy come
went to lunch with him halfway through
lunch he actually mentions
you know this and that and this and that
i was like no
yeah i said i know you know that's an
issue he never really pushed the issue i
was like yeah i know i get a lot of
these guys that say this kind of like
he he was kind of just trying to feel me
out he never really said
this is why a lot of people just are
desperate for money it's crazy
yeah this is this is a thing so i'm
gonna
i'll tell you the one about new york
because he's not desperate for money
right right well i guess what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that like the
i think you get like people want fast
money you get so much [ __ ] on the
internet because so many people just
like
that's why it's so easy for people on
youtube to get so
big real quick just gotta like either
have a lot of money or pretend like they
have a lot of money and they'll just
blow up all you gotta do is have like a
[ __ ]
pretend like you own a bunch of [ __ ] or
drive a really nice car or talk about
how to make money
and you automatically get a bunch of
desperate poor people or people who are
struggling
that are going to follow you because
there's nothing anybody wants more than
money
i i've actually it's funny because
i've actually had a couple of people
contact me
who were basically saying like they
wanted to try and set up a channel
with me where i basically i'd be like a
guru
and it was like they want to turn you
into yeah they turned me into a guru and
i'm like i'm not to do that oh you're
going to be a [ __ ] fake guru
yeah exactly i did a whole podcast about
that with this dude coffeezilla it's
hilarious
yeah i'm not i i yeah i i saw part i saw
like half of that that
great it was it was um it was on uh with
skype right yeah i was on yeah i was on
zoom yeah right so
um yeah i'm not i'm not doing that
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
no it's like you know and you know yeah
we can get you in front of a lamborghini
we could use it what are you talking
about i'm a federal probation what do
you think my probation officer
what's the [ __ ] oh my god you want me
climbing out of a lamborghini
i can already see the thumbnails oh yeah
the tai lopez matt cox
imagine him like standing in front like
reading a book and sitting on a
lamborghini
why don't you do it what i'm like i'm
not doing that i'm not doing it because
i'm not i'm not gonna you could you
could have your own course this is
horrible
imagine that that was the worst thing it
was the course the big thing was the
course like
you understand the course and you can do
this and it's like i don't
i mean you know and it's all like the
money the money and the money yeah but
you understand
what i want to do is i want to do the
true crime i want to get these stories
made
and the whole thing is it's like look if
it was about money
then i could go do something for money
i'd have done that a year ago
yeah i'm on a course of action i'm
sticking with that course of action
i can always go work in in real estate
or
sell cars or work for fedex or do
something if i wanted to just have a
decent job and just you know make a
little bit of money or if i wanted to be
a fake gurus i can always do that yeah
i'm doing this now no we'll take care of
this stop bro stop stop
stop not only i mean it's bad enough to
be a fake guru
but then just to to be like partners
with a bunch of people who are
creating your fake guru persona and be
and be business partners with those kind
of people that's
people recipe for [ __ ] disaster a lot
of people do yeah
i mean they're making crazy money yeah i
know but
that's what i'm saying i could always do
that if i would need to take they take
advantage of desperate people though
i would feel this is coming from me this
is really going to be [ __ ] up
i would feel so fake and so you know
what i mean it
wouldn't it feel like an advantage of
people
no look i have no problems about that i
had no problem yeah but you didn't get
advantage of people you took advantage
of banks
i'm saying i'm saying i don't have a a
moral problem i have a feeling that i
would feel like it was [ __ ]
yeah like look it like it is right
you know what i'm saying like i'm i'm
doing something that i don't feel like
is [ __ ] like it's legitimate
and it feels good as opposed to so
so look so i don't care so so i got
these guys that are constantly
contacting me which is what who are they
sell them out right here i don't know
their name
come on i'm gonna sell them let's tell
them there's only only one guy's name i
know and i'm not gonna use it because i
feel bad so
i didn't even tell this like on my
channel i did it
um i did a story or i did a i did a vlog
the other day called um
called scams okay and i talk about how
people are reaching out to me saying
this but i very briefly kind of go over
and i
almost told the story about this guy
and then i i stopped and i thought nah
if he watches it and you know i thought
i don't want to
so but then i thought sorry but then i
went back and i looked on my cell phone
and i realized
it's been three weeks this guy was
texting you once or twice a week
for six months it's been three weeks and
you haven't heard from him
it was absolutely he was he had been
talking to me the whole time thinking at
some point i'm coaxing this guy along
and i'm going to get him into a point
where we're building up a friendship and
he's going to help me
you're wrong about that right
foreign